[Music]
the trial for Brazil's former president
has begun jair bolsono is accused of
abusing his power by claiming the
electoral system could be rigged and
using public funds to spread fake news
Well Monica yanakiev joins us now from
outside the superior electoral Court in
Brasilia Monica what are the chances of
bolsonaro not actually being able to run
for president again because of this
trial
[Music]
well there are great chances we've
spoken to analysts several of them also
with his own supporters and he himself
has shown that he's he's quite
sure that he will be convicted that
means that he would not be able to run
for office for the next eight years that
means not being able to run for office
in two Municipal elections the next one
will be next year and for two
presidential elections so it is a very
serious trial because it will Define
somehow Brazil's political future but
also now it is still a very popular
figure among conservatives and he would
have been a strong Contender against
current president Louisiana
in next year's elections how has
bolsonaro himself reacted to this
foreign
so he gave an interview yesterday where
he said that it was not fair that he had
just had a meeting with ambassadors and
spoke that he just said what he thought
that's not what the accusation says they
say that he had a meeting in the middle
of a campaign it was broadcasted on
national television it was uh it went on
all social media thousands of people
heard that he was actually stating that
the system the voting system could be
rigged the elections uh the results
could be a fraud and he presented
absolutely no evidence to back this up
so they say they're accusing him of
spreading fake news he on the other hand
is on what just arrived in the southern
state of Hugh Granger dusu where he has
many supporters and he's meeting with
them to show that he's a popular figure
the strategy of his party the liberal
party is to have him as a king's maker
to help him make elect Mayors some 1 200
1 500 of the more than 5 000 Mayors
um for net and during next year's
Municipal elections so they're he's
still a strong political figure and
they're hoping that he will help elect
more conservatives in Congress and in
the cities and elsewhere in Brazil okay
thank you so much we'll be keeping a
very close eye on that trial that's
Monica yanakiev from Brasilia